was a tight back and forth affair for
the aces in game two they said all right
enough with the games y'all are going
home folks we didn't just have a beat
down we had a historic beat down the
wnba record for threes in the game was
18. that's regular season and postseason
included the aces said 18 is cute we'll
take 23 of them please chelsea gray was
having herself a party and turns out
mercury was in retrograde great went
seven of eight from three the team shot
64 from beyond the arc
37-point win the second largest in wnba
playoff history ladies have mercy
or don't that's cool too into round two
they go
right now as a as a team we're playing
our best basketball on both ends like
you want to peak at the right time and
for me individually that's what i'm
feeling i've always told them
offense is offense it's whatever i want
defense
but obviously tonight
the offense was special so i would be
amiss to not give them credit we were
just taking what the defense was giving
us it's something that we
been working on i mean it's something
that's just a part of each of our games
so for us to just showcase it i think
it's just a matter of time that we've
been doing it more
consistently with all that here's how
the first round looks into what is going
to be the semifinals for the aces they
await the winner of the storm and
mystics in the four verse five matchup
game two of that series is on sunday and
the storm win that one they head here to
vegas for the final four if the mystics
take it game three will be on tuesday
and that could be some much needed rest
for the aces before what turns into now
a best of five series so uh historic
night and uh fans excited because that's
a big step towards maybe getting a
parade here in a little bit yeah it's
been amazing watching them i mean
they're they're phenomenal and now
they're breaking records and they're
taking names while doing it so they're
not messing around yeah it's just the
beginning
all right